[Musica]
la ragazzina in panchina non gioca da
tantissimo tempo quando improvvisamente
il suo allenatore si gira dice scaldati
lei si alza si fa la coda ed entra la
coppia sta in questa casa scarna senza
arredamento in penombra
ma improvvisamente lei comincia di vi
aspetta lì potevamo mettere una libreria
e qui potremmo metterci il divano rosso
e magari di il tavolino per i bambini
l'uomo 55 anni è al quarto colloquio di
lavoro della giornata non ho tanta
fiducia in quello che possa accadere ma
improvvisamente si apre una porta è una
donna elegante dice beh abbiamo deciso
che prendiamo lei che cosa unisce tutte
queste storie ma soprattutto che cosa
unisce noi una cosa ed è che tutti
desideriamo essere felici ma questa
parola felicità è una parola strana è
una parola insolita difficile qualcosa
insolente è una parola che recitiamo con
grandissima cura come se fosse un fatto
intimo come se non avessimo davvero il
coraggio di dirci che ci piacerebbe
essere felici
eppure questo vorrei fare nei prossimi
sette minuti parlari magari anche un po
sfacciatamente di felicità perché la
felicità è tutt'altro che un fatto
teorico ed è come un po come una
missione spaziale che per decollare ha
bisogno di due condizioni la prima
condizione è molto semplice per essere
felici noi dobbiamo essere noi cioè
dobbiamo essere una rete dobbiamo essere
insieme e dobbiamo essere insieme in
modo tale che uno più uno faccia 3
questo è quasi banale a dirlo ma sono
stati fatti studi anche tremendi nel
passato su questo tema mi vien in mente
federico ii federico ii ordino alle
valli e di prendere dei bambini
nati di allattarli di levi da mangiare
di lavarli vestirli ma di non parlargli
perché voleva sapere questi bambini che
lingua avrebbero adoperato in mancanza
di con test bene tutti questi bambini
morivano prima dell'adolescenza
perché da solo l'uomo non vive l'uomo ha
bisogno di chiarezza ha bisogno di
affettività ha bisogno degli altri e
questo ripeto lo sappiamo ma ogni tanto
dovremmo ricordarcelo berton a russell
ci dice che felice chi esce da se stesso
e felice chi da non per ottenere
immediatamente qualcosa in concambio ma
perché nel dare trova una modalità di
realizzazione tema semplice eppure con
quanta rapidità siamo passati dalle case
di ringhiera aperte nelle quali si
condivideva l'insalata il pollo alle
porte blindate nelle quali le relazioni
che abbiamo con gli altri sono spesso
mediate da avvocati ecco la prima
condizione quindi è quella di essere
insieme ma insieme per fare cosa e qui
facciamo appello a un altro studioso
indiano al giorno appathurai che ci dice
bene la seconda condizione per essere
felice aspirare al futuro cioè
reinstallare progetti di vita e
desiderare tema importante anche questo
il futuro il futuro è uno dei tre tempi
in realtà i tempi sarebbero tantissimi
ma quelli ai quali siamo abituati sono
tre il passato il presente il futuro
esistono ancora questi tuoi tempi forse
non troppo
pensiamo al passato il passato è un po
scomparso perché non abbiamo il tempo di
indagarlo poi ognuno di noi qui alle sue
passioni avessero moltissimi libri mi
piace la musica e mi piacciono i film
ogni tanto passa da casa e guardo i miei
libri i miei film mi de ski ma a roma il
tempo di rivedermi aimag di rice aveva
il tempo di sentirmi tocchi mezzo di
leggermi canetti la risposta è no e mi
riguarda non è
e io guardo loro questo perché il tempo
che viviamo si è compresso in quello che
che da galasso rusco chiama presentismo
la visione la capacità di vivere
l'istante ma forse la capacità di stare
solamente chiusi nell'istante siamo
diventati dg freni c è la parola è molto
bella ma sapete cos'è la dg fra nina è
una prova semplice ci riguarda in molti
di giffoni e questo immaginate che state
facendo una cosa qualsiasi mentre la
state facendo team sentite un'email che
cosa fate finite quello che state
facendo andate a vedere chi li scrive
andiamo a vedere chi ci scrive ma mentre
siamo andati a vedere che ci scrive
siamo alla terza riga se sentiamo il
fischietto di whatsapp cosa facciamo
andiamo a vedere immediatamente chi
cifra ma ecco questa eterodirezione
nella quale i nostri istanti non sono
più governati da noi è un altra novità
di quello che viviamo
ma attenzione non sto dicendo che questo
sia peggio di prima e solo diverso
noi viviamo un tempo diverso solo che in
questo tempo diverso è importante per
molti di noi riprendere in mano il
proprio futuro
quelle che si chiamano progetti di vita
qui siamo centinaia di persone ma senza
alzate di mano
quanti di noi sinceramente hanno
progetti di vita cioè cose che vedono
che sono conficcati in un tempo futuro
che so nel 2031 il 2040 quanti di noi
stanno studiando risparmiando per cose
che vogliano fa 10 15 anni
pochi che invece dovremmo recuperare
proprio questo immaginiamo di avere un
po di creare un'agenda del futuro nella
quale non mettiamo solamente che scade
la manutenzione della caldaia ma
l'allora scuola dei figli
i viaggi che vogliamo fare questo noi
dobbiamo reimparare a farlo avevano
prospettiva che sia pluriennale queste
però sono condizioni quali psicologi
quasi psicologiche e non basta per
essere felici ci sono anche delle
condizioni oggettive molto concrete che
si chiamano benessere ma anche qui che
cos'è il benessere la storia del
benessere appassionantissima ci sono
state e ci sono infiniti ragionamenti e
studi sul benessere che che variano
anche culturalmente in asia il figlio
la felicità interna lorda o il bill il
benessere interno lordo ocse il lavoro
sul wellbeing index le nazioni unite
tanti studi si occupano in essere in
italia e noi adoperiamo il best di staff
che il benessere equo e sostenibile
io penso una cosa molto semplice ma
anche molto concreta perché ci dice che
in fondo per dare benessere alle
collettività
basterebbe avere immagini mentre dodici
capitoli e sono dodici capitoli che
dicono che se le persone sono in grado
di curarsi di far studiare i propri
figli
se abbiamo lavoro nel caso in cui lo
perdiamo lo ritroviamo se le relazioni
sociali ci sono se abbiamo stabilità
economica se tutto questo avviene in un
paese nel quale le istituzioni hanno un
buon rapporto con noi
il paesaggio è decente l'aria
respirabile l'acqua deri bile e c'è
ricerca verso il futuro e servizi beh
noi potremmo stare bene e allora questi
dodici capitoli che sono interessanti
non solo in sé ma anche perché sono
misurabili ci fanno venire in mente a
questo punto che forse le relazioni
sociali
l'aspirazione del futuro e degli
indicatori potrebbero diventare
attenzione di due luoghi e quali sono i
due luoghi nei quali si può creare la
felicità è un primo luogo è semplice ed
è il pubblico la felicità è anche un
tema di pubblica amministrazione che
dovrebbe avere al centro delle proprie
politiche
il benessere delle persone pensate per
un attimo alle città nelle quali viviamo
ci sono città nelle quali ci sono
assessorati a parchi pubblici cimiteri
sport e giovani come puoi mettere
insieme delle cose così diverse e
produrre dei risultati allora la prima
idea molto semplice se il benessere al
centro dell'attenzione pubblica
creiamo un organizzazione pubblica
suddivisa per capitolo di benessere non
fa male a nessuno
ogni cosa è misurabile
e noi possiamo con trasparenza capire se
il territorio al quale viviamo sta
facendo dei progressi però questo è il
pubblico poi ci siamo noi e noi siamo
importanti nella costruzione del proprio
benessere e della nostra felicità e
anche noi dovremmo fare delle cose le
cose che noi dobbiamo fare non sono
tante sono tre e anche questa abbastanza
semplici prima cosa dovremo re imparare
ad essere curiosi e quindi essere
consapevoli di dove siamo e a prendere
contatto con la nostra situazione
la conoscenza riduce il rischio questo
significa capire se siamo protetti
capire dove vogliamo andare capire il
nostro fine lavoro e capire che cosa
vogliamo fare da grandi ho molto grandi
secondo te ma l'ho già accennato re
installiamo il futuro cioè riaccendiamo
progetti di vita
questo peraltro anche a livello
affettivo è un grandissimo motore di
benessere per le persone che ci stanno
fianco e la terza cosa questo è più
difficile dobbiamo un po reimparare a
decidere perché quando tu cammini sulle
uova delle volte ti sembra difficile
decidere ma se il mondo corre e tu sei
fermo la distanza fate il mondo cresce
di continuo e questa è una cosa che non
possiamo permetterci questi i piccoli
spunti di un piccolo intervento ma ma
per finirlo e poi per tornare alla
nostra vita e quindi sa come anche noi
in fondo dovremo uscire da qui con
qualche domanda da facili mi permetto di
dirvi questa sera quando tornate a casa
in albergo pagate a farmi delle domande
è la prima domanda semplice come lo
immagino fra dieci anni dove penso dire
essere con chi sa fare cosa che cosa che
cos'è il me che io colloco nel 2027
seconda domanda che cosa posso fare per
le personali quali voglio bene e che
cosa vogliono le persone che sia
ecco dove le sto portando e se non le
sto portando perché non devo
accompagnarli farmi accompagnare in
qualche luogo e la terza domanda è c'è
qualcuno che può darmi una mano a
realizzare i miei progetti perché nulla
è più tremendo della privatizzazione
delle ansie e dei desideri e niente più
liberatorio che metterlo in comune con
gli altri
grazie
[Applauso]